time for the longing one of them
television journal of the important in
terms of the hour
cultural you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation of a laundry list for
what happened
later on
laundry the world's most ahmed wants
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
its own gene
good evening this is frank night
mary introduce our collaborative for
this edition of the mounting problems
though
mister william bradford purely editor of
the american mercury
and mister henry has looked contributing
editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable joseph mama profit
united state senator from wisconsin
the opinions expressed unnecessarily
those of the speaker
senate democrats they are yours of
course
snow that you're one of the most
controversial political figures of our
planet
and this is your
apparent sent your rather
overwhelming victory in the wisconsin
primaries
now sir uh... what uh... brings you
least at this time
your program runs from june
and uh...
i believe that uh... also this week you
decline in morrill hall
wallet bridgeport right
and uh... course at your is know that
uh... in connecticut
that's there home state of uh... a man
that you had a few words with senator
bill seven
now sir uh... uh...
what's the purpose of your going into
into connecticut is it to defeat senator
brown a ban on how to try to help defeat
senator badan
my proposal
mister here will be about this time of
the proposed and soon
trolls thirteen states of as opposed to
bring
important facts to the american people
you sooner
i got a very strong feeling that
most of our people in public life
underestimate the intelligence the
american people
they try to arguing tell people to vote
i think in need really
give the people fire
and then you can go home and on
worry there will try contact bridgeport
connecticut
dunstan you're correct
that is that when you have to say that
you are opening a twelve or thirteen
state uh... drag now in support of the
national ticket
i think aluminium remember
iron on schedule to speak and some
thirteen or fourteen states
where they have clothes some soil
contact
senator dot of people came into your
state and wisconsin
to try to defeat you in the primaries
and it seemed to work the other way
now don't you think that perhaps when
you go to the states may have that sort
of thing
who true but uh...
thus far has okayed that's right
insurrection
there's a group of
i do not intend to go into those plates
until the people of the vote
i don't intend to go in and and discuss
the local
when running for congress two percent
anti-immigrant those states and give the
american people
cold document
soliton career
extent to which communism
has been directing our foreign policy
are suicidal foreign policy if you
please
and if the american people want more
then they can look for the president
ministration let me say this
the left my appeal is
is largely major democrat
now i feel that the millions of
americans along with a democrat ticket
for just a little while we're on the
market just as much the heat communism
just as much
as the average republican
and i think it is up to those
uh... loyal democrats to realign
as of today they don't
have a park in washington
it would weaken
uh... have a chain
is my voting record what do you think a
lot of democrats came in and voted for
you and the wisconsin election
i don't think you know
our normal but for this for three years
ago the democratic vote with forty seven
percent of the total republicans will
fifty three percent
this year we had a m
it's giving these figures are eighty
three percent republican vote
something for some democrat votes
and most of the democrat
apparently voted for mccarthy because i
carried
the democrat war
normally about how to make sure the
republican work
prove my contention that is that in this
fight against communism
because the democrats with his
republican
and for that reason i don't want any
state told people
one of the broader interpretation of
your own victory in wisconsin that you
see it
one symptom of the number one
uh... it was not a vote for workers
uh... it was a ferryboat on an issue
on all important should the american
people recognize that the one
laughter from the issue was the issue of
communism
tied up with the korean war
world war close to it
here for three strikes in corporate
america
the names of the american people are
six way down deep inside
that has been going on
fidget was i'd like to consider a
tribute to address it
but it does not it was a vote upon
all-important issue and i just hope
many of our
new friends realize the five years
the issue this little implies senator by
saying that they didn't vote for
mccarthy era platitudes become something
of a simple about to a large group of
americans now
just what do you believe you symbolizing
the american political scene now
to recruit like do you prefer
close to the figure is
let's put it this way
many people
heaven waiting
for someone to
extent
terms which are suicidal foreign policy
has been dictated from occurring
rather than waiting for someone to
really get a
option the women like senator williams
of
i think my people in wisconsin reporting
an approval of a
fight against communism
they sell of american entry
and uh...
reward voting their reporting for joe
mccarthy would not have happened to be
the recipient of the vote and i
certainly
appreciative that there would you say
the other side of that coin is that you
were the recipient of
all the protest vote
and wisconsin
i mean is that they were voting for you
in order to protest against
uh... what what you outline that have
been the failures of the administration
last month which will be which
senator i want to ask you about this
word
mccarthyism
am i right supposing that the first one
who use that word with a little at a
more in testimony before the tidings
committee
lu moore first used in
uh... honestly cracked myself but i
think it was first used by leavenworth
or by the daily worker but the testimony
now is the forty top communist left new
york
and decided how they would
fight mccarthy
and the three of them crying the phrase
mccarthyism
uh... as the date of the promoters
the day before a lot more customer test
for the day after thanksgiving
but that's the argument is either the
fairly workers publication of the door
the alarm at a more testimony that the
u_s_ time views or the the testimony by
uh... howard rushmore the forty
communist methods that week
decline in the phrase mccarthyism and
user
i want to ask you hear something about
an appointed came up
in the testimony
as the congressional testimony about the
institute of pacific relations
uh... this is about a year ago
and it was a letter
written by the uh... secretary of the
ice t_ r_ two-way mister barnett asking
about a meeting they were going to have
it now i'm bob and the people that they
ought to invite for that meeting
and there
uh... william lockwood their said here
and in writing as secretary of the
i_p_r_
another possibility we might consider if
someone from out of office are simpson's
cole and his
meeting alger hiss
mentioned adlai stevenson one of marxist
special assistance
well that must mean adlai stevenson
because they're
there and he was one of knox especially
business and there was no stevens
now why in your opinion
would and his back in nineteen forty two
have recommended adlai stevenson
as a participant in that meeting though
what qualifications did adlai stevenson
has as a that's a far eastern expert at
that time
full appropriations bills are just
lovely
to keep in mind that
cold hillerman recommend alger hiss
as the name under oath
sometime
as either communist or an espionage
assailant afoot but they say that's not
good enough for the stevenson's record
into great detail this time
because we have just completed
since our research in italy stevens
within a year
uh... and uh...
nine ten pm review of that
i'm a nationwide network
and television hopeful so
soon after a review of the picture of
students some of his laboratory
criticism
just recently stevenson's history of at
least even some
since the time he entered the
agriculture department nineteen thirty
three
relocation program has centered
after i get the history of stevenson
uh... if the american people want to
make an having
i don't think so
well uh... senator i gather from what
you say that it's
they had to insure that
if you are not the void
personalities
and year thirteen states that you expect
this weekend
loan number of we're getting the facts
the american people
mister hewitt so it's easy to talk about
communism generate talk about the
sell-off in china and korea jenner
but my shoe colour rules a tree
mister cole who have those who've been
responsible
for the suicidal for info
it's a waste of the speakers time when
the audience
and i don't intend to ever get up and
general term
talk about trees and talk about some
you see foreign policy is michael topsy
dozens
treasonous vital topsy doesn't just go
it's created my ministry schism in with
me
i think those of us would like to hear
from people
from around the watchtower
mastery of the intelligence
to recognize that richard
and land if i may use a
refer to use in wisconsin is really good
two main
we should be taken down from those
watched hours and should not be
representing the american people i don't
intend to
ever reported
giving the names of
traitors giving the names of communists
for discover them important position
plus i really appreciate it very much
for your being with us tonight
thank thank you mr
the editorial board for this edition of
the long-chain cause go close mister
william bradford ily
and mister henry has left
our distinguished guests was the
honorable joseph kamikaze
united state senator from wisconsin
active worlds they respond again
here from a quarter
here again the world series long green
card
paula rise above american and national
day for me
mounting losses exclusively but i mean
all the games including the world's fair
the most on it walks in the world of
sports is launching in the world's most
on it wafts
the only watch in history
do intend world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and so many
others for accuracy in fields of precise
time
how that's why throughout the world
no other name on a watch
carries the prestige of laundry
the world's most haunted watch
infor
we want to first choice
less discriminating people the world
over
and yet the you know that you made by
the end all and all by and probably give
the launching lots
for as little as seventy one fifty
laundry in the world's most all at once
premium product of a laundry list all
what happened
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all the highest debt
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening
at the same time for the laundry in
public
a television journal of the important
thing
broadcast on the top of launching in the
world's most on and off
and whatnot distinguished companions of
the world all night long
reminding you that long gene and with no
water
also service
by more than four thousand leaving
joanna
who proudly display this sample
agency fall on gene what
stars forty dollars mr mrs laws on the
c_b_s_ television network
time for the com and none of them
television journal of the important in
terms of the aisle
also you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation of the laundry list of
all what happened
later on long jane the world's most on
it watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on its own gene
good evening this is frank night
may i introduce our talented players for
this edition of the laundry in costco
mister william bradford puree
editor of the american mercury and
mister hardy for noted correspondent and
often
our distinguished guests for this
evening is doctor caused a lot american
labor party represent
dr lamont
uh... our viewers of course many of them
are
know that you are somewhat controversial
political figure
and i'm sure they welcome you tonight
and will extend to you the same degree
of tolerance that day extended to the
views expressed here
as an analyst program by senator
mccarthy
now at tonight's error and i believe
your candidate for the united states
senate in new york is that correct that
astronauts wife tastes campaign for
political office
and uh... and and now you are the
candidate for the american labor party
in new york that's true
and is that party affiliated with the
progressive party nationally
yes uh... are a national ticket
that our president has spent some time
and effort by thousands of our bass
now have to make the party is the new
york unit of that party now that's the
party that there are viewers remember it
was created by mister wallace in
nineteen hundred forty-eight
texas yes
now serve her
you are
have then
most of your active lifetime i believe
as an american who was generally
friendly toward the soviet union
is that correct sergio youth so classify
i think you could think that yes ask a
question um...
of doctor about
the british you're in the world for us
today is whether we can
have peace with russia rich spending
billions of dollars on the premise that
uh... we have to stave off russian
attractive so far
sending troops abroad to europe
now do you think it's possible
to make peace with russian without flew
force of arms
i certainly do think it's possible and
of course if you resort to force of arms
that will result in a terrible thing
well wallets nobody can win
i believe that in spite of the soviet
union to the states which i think how
many
inspite of mistakes on the american side
we can get together over the conference
table and weight these things out
making a start with a relaxing the
tensions that i was assisting in the
world today just what would be your
method in doing that getting together so
i mean that's what you have to do well
yet so i would approve of a
perhaps the five teleconference or to
power conference on the top level with
total fallon truman whoever is president
of the united states
and carrying out the idea that
uh... the anticommunist nehru suggested
recently
of talking these things over in a five
pollock on plants around the conference
table
now there been any such conferences
issues and now we've
usually been disillusioned why do you
think this time after the workout hyatt
dot com is that what like al
but of course i believe we should
make immediate steps toward relaxing
these tensions by getting an immediate
cease-fire in korea
and then perhaps leading china into the
united nations
and then restoring well trade which has
been disrupted over the past few years
how do we got a cease-fire
well i think of that
the best plan has been suggested is too
let the prisoner of war as you are
present
and all of us for settlement between
four and a withdrawals
switzerland sweden
poland and czechoslovakia
and let that be settled after the
cease-fire actions has been made on the
present based
i think the north koreans and the
chinese would agree
such a compromise and it could be wiped
out
and say this and i thought i which is
going on over there in korea
closer now and order to
capture views purposes
is it true to say we will mention that
you are one of the americans who is
generally friendly towards soviet union
now you made several trips to to russia
didn't you during the thirties
i'm making threats misty you know we in
nineteen thirty two and nineteen thirty
eight
and and and during that
bad period a year or one of the
americans who thought that there was
something enormously hopeful for mankind
going on in russia
that's right but i was never an
apologist for them i always thought the
mistakes on the evils and the soviet
union
it seems to me that any country has
voted
it's good and bad sides and i think they
toward russia
uh... now for instance the
courage trials in nineteen thirty seven
uh... it
you're one of the americans who thought
that those files were
properly and where honor both trials and
and that the government the soviet union
was proper and and and
carrying out that first well i think
that innocent people thought that and i
think mister yoy but so far the great
more self-confidence and i think that
that they would just one and i have a
supporter
it winston churchill
when one of his books they said that he
believed they were necessary regretful
now if you have also uh... is it fair to
say that
that that you've been generally critical
of organized religions and the christian
religion particularly
well uh...
and i've been critical of of theology
and plentiful
ideas in the tapes existed you eat
but naturally i support the testament
ideals and teachings of jesus
and uh... in my own philosophy bring
both in cost humidity's been your belief
that the christian church in western
europe for instance
has been age
a reactionary political as well
i would always want to be specific on
that and and say what katie exactly what
was their policy because in many cases
many catholics to
have taken a liberal policy and social
affairs and all fighting for
international peace today
unwilling to make any overall
condemnation of the tapes a religion or
a country
now you have also been a member or an
officer
of a number of organizations that have
been labels severity by the government
the united states
now sir do you have any any regrets
as to those memberships
well i can't think that i do miss tilly
as a matter of fact the halls of basic
resting
it seems to me with unconstitutional and
illegal
and it was carried out as you know
without giving any of these
organizations
access to testify and answer the charges
against
well served now with that
with that background what do you regard
as a candidate for the united states
senate
what do you regard as the most important
issue before the american people today
well i think
there are two most important issues if i
may put it that way the restoration of
civil liberties for everybody in this
country capitalist way kids socialist
communist
the enemies of communists uh...
catholics and a siesta everything else
and the second big issue is
international peace and assault
uh... those two issues i'm emphasizing
in my campaign and of course they had
tied up together right now in the first
issue the restoration of
civil liberties affected by that you
mean that
civil civil liberties are threatened
today that they need restoring old law
and threatened they have been suppressed
right left here
and if he doesn't want all the time the
field of of governmental
violation
uh... to uh... non governmental
violation in private entertainment feels
like uh... radio even television movies
and publishing
which would you say that uh... senator
mccarthy is a is a part of that threat
i'm afraid he has because mccartney has
kept the american people start up
over a an alleged threat of communist
insurrection here
and it seems to me has gone much too far
in the direction of suppressing actually
the bill of rights and making
everybody's scared to death
so that people now and that's what they
call self-censorship
and i wanted to let not go on and on
them and uh... not stick their necks out
they just keep quiet
when he's got a mating everybody's
scared to death do you believe that our
very large number of americans are
living in fear today uh... of senator
mccarthy in what he stands for well not
so much out
mccarthy himself
as the the the fear that he is startup
that fear of government people losing
their jobs because they refused dot
some vague relationship to a communist
organization back in nineteen thirty two
all this i consider going pretty far
sprite
but it's not only mccarthy the democrats
have a man like that in his name is the
cap
and he is just as bad in my opinion and
more powerful actually in the senate of
the united states
lesser-known this problem of peace which
year
i believe that mode both major part is
that from debate the issue that more
people are interested in
narrower
uh... in in western europe you've
expressed in this year
painted on career
in western europe are you critical of
our maintaining troops in western europe
well i i am indeed i think that it's not
necessary
faith that there is a very a danger of
soviet military aggression in western
europe because that is the latest white
they way through propaganda and taking
advantage of the economic conditions
now as it happens we are bringing about
bad economic conditions in western
europe
that's one of the great troubles with
our policy doctor let me on the rapper i
did i ask this question because it is
pregnant uh... suppose we withdrew
all our financial aid and all of our
troops from europe
do you think that the communist but
pretty much leave europe along do you
think you're a picture of the european
countries themselves would go communist
internally
not necessarily privately myself and
hope
about the european countries of england
france and italy
might uh... established reform
government labor government such as you
have an independent but they would have
no allegiance to russia not necessarily
there was still be strong communist
movement in those countries
but what america has done it seems to me
still fighting with armaments program on
them and disrupting east-west trade is
to depress that living standards
and in that way
opened the gates through the communist
party is more than before
because communist as you know five on
economic misery hanan bed economic
condition
the doctor is a final question
uh... would you tell our audience
kind of america you would like to see
during the next four years
well high believe although it was a
great country where the great tradition
but the fact addition has been betrayed
since the death of franklin d_ runs
about
i believe that would be reestablishment
of peace we can reestablish civil
liberties here
and then start date march
renewal march in america toward economic
security and abundance
for everyone in this country
is it fair to say that you are a
socialist image you want to see a repeat
restored in and you want to see this
government proceed
further in the direction of socialism
that's right
floorplan socialism went democratic
means putting it into affect and not
revolution
you think private property should be on
by the state
fast
well not all private property mr beta
the main means of production and
distribution it's closer and i'm certain
that our viewers have enjoyed these
forthright views from you sir
and thank you very much for being with
us
the opinions expressed as evening are
necessarily those of the speaker
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promised those laws
mister william bradford killing
and the mister hardy for it
our distinguished guests was tough
because the law
american labor party represent
and the it
world series product
the best days of the year for baseball
and this year again world series
yes all of our supposed
who's gone team offered exclusively what
i mean all the game
including the world series
the most all night watching sports
is launching
the world's most honored watch
the only watch in history
the winds and morals their grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals and so many
others for accuracy in fields of precise
timing
now that's why you throughout the world
no other name on a watch carries the
prestige of laundry
the world's most audit walkins for
the watch our first choice
with discriminating people the world
over
and yet the you know
that you made by handle
or fly and probably get the launching
watch
for as little as seven b one fifty
long jane the world's most on it watch
premium product of the logging with lol
bluffs company
cincy
sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest debt
we invited to join us
every monday wednesday and friday
evening at the same time for the long
came from
the television journal of the important
business of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most otherwise
distinguished companion
for the world on a voluntary
reminding you know
that long-chain
with all options
are sold and service
from coast to coast
by more than four thousand
leading dilemma
proudly display their family
agency on on james
wal-mart
it slightly picked the winner on the
c_b_s_ television the first
time for the compton monitor
television journal of the important
issues of the aisle
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on long jane the world's most on
it locked
and what
distinguished companion to the world
ahmed long gene
believing business frank nice
now introduce our color codes for this
edition of the launching collins co
mister william bradford killing editor
of the american mercury and mister eliot
pain
associate editor of united nations world
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable fuller walked
governor of the state of florida
who are at the earth first uh...
no you as one of the more controversial
political figures in the south
uh...
they remember
uh... little
engagement that you had with the
senator people over during his
investigation
and tonight i'm sure that our viewers
would like
some of your
expressions as to
the political situation in florida
now for sir
uh... we've had governor talmadge
illness programmer
a few days ago he told us his position
we have certain other southern governors
what's your position in the present
national campaigns
mister u_n_ one hundred percent plus
for stevenson and spark
well now are
you're one of the radical governors in
the south are you conservative where do
you fit in this political firm
uh... mister you know i think
you might appropriately and aptly
described me as a liberal conservative
well
garnered as the uh...
other work liberal conservative leader
and he's s cpc
not a composer efi pc a mystery and
leave believe in the constitution
at i believe all good americans do and
weary because tuition it doesn't give
the federal government the power of pass
on their feet bc uh...
that could be enforced with jr senators
europe's leading writers ryan
well i don't know so much about that i'm
an american forest but i believe in
treatment of body friend right
given everybody an equal opportunity
that job
our business to stevenson's positions on
those issues uh...
altogether salute you sir
where all of them
they come they recently then most
positions on that subject during
including that general eisenhower's
well i think i guess what his position
in the vacillate showing changes from
database so that i can keep up with the
hollywood latest position this pain
pacific when a general eisenhower
theater widely-publicized visit to your
state recently
uh... what was effective his trip to a
uh... well it's hard to say in this do
you have been in politics for twenty
five years in about all the time learn
to do is to make a lot of yet
throttled poses an x
writer even uh... cellmark ways i might
be assumed allexperts
but he was well-received that great many
people turn out to see him in he was
treated
florida hospitality in cordiality
the feeling here that he got more
hospitality then you'll get bogged down
that you think that also applies to
where the effect that carried burns
might have been his switched to
eisenhower
for governor burned is one of the most
beloved and revered figures in this
trial
and uh... we have real defection for him
in the southwest
how about if in a political leaders
position in the south will greatly
influence their vote siva
great number of people in the south
just about everybody in the south is i
suspect most of my on the north and west
do they old
their independence when it comes to
casten of hope you have a lot of
republicans in florida don't you
governor
yes it we've got a very large republican
infiltration in the florida in recent
years and i may say we welcome them
because they're they're almost all of
them well-heeled and
uh... capable of doing a lot to develop
our state and make fine citizens but
barry
you might say unsatisfactory boat
will serve now about florida and
uh... has industrialization preceded
this fast in florida that has in other
states
very very fast mister hewitt for many
years
leave alone won't tourism and
agriculture but short on
industrialization but none of the burn
up some policies of roosevelt
uh... we have proceeded rapidly in the
industrialization of florida ali
industrious
fast moving up alongside allied with
cultural
an hour to arrest
when a about terrorism uh...
how important is tourism to the economy
of florida mister hewitt it isn't
almost all-important the people of
florida
have approval
annual income of about three and a half
billion dollars
about one billion of those three and a
half billion dollars is derived from
tourism
so you can see that about one out of
every three and i have dollars we take
in
comes from these splendid finan affluent
people from other states to come to
florida
paresh relaxation in reinvigorate
shannon quotation i also account for
uh... divorces governor
well if you haven't come down to america
liberation but none deposits
because i was one of the many
are you might say
facets of florida's charm well this
friday go to complete list of states is
arkansas in nevada and of course is that
mister hewitt we had a little that
handicap they have a
believer six days sixty coming six we
try to his reform of those two states
and you have to live in florida
for the full period of ninety days
before you can follow the horses
adhesion make more money from each of
our state for c
lawyer says long we keep them that the
board is then they are coerced but
i believe it's money well spent because
they get a new lease on life and
recapture a whole lot of lost you fly
live down then and just everywhere they
have benefited me improve
it's an area saying that go into
paradise that can be achieved without
dying in the campaign that is gambling
including agonized
knows that we have suppressed gambling
in florida almost completely from more
than fifty years fitted operated just
about as open as i areas uh... filling
stations but
and the last three or four years we have
just about suppressed
illegal gambling we have
on gambling apparently a few of the
arming of the horse tracks and all the
facts that i live with
in florida now
uh... you rather see risk risk if you
get an a dot htm off
a card game where there's any
money only once stated for senator keep
over was responsible for that change for
him how he came down there and that a
lot of shatman hollering and screaming
and i learn about it after we had uh...
made a good start toward suppressing it
uh... he is
was using a special senate committee for
the purpose of promote himself up by the
media came down got a lot of headlines
and a lot of tub opinion
annoys making down in history
well i was it was some of the people
over i believe the charges that uh...
and some of those people around miami
we're good friends of yours who were
involved in that dan optimistic viewing
all men who run for president good
friend everybody let it be a good friend
to it
of the fact is an under my
administration
uh... illegal gambling and part of
adventure fresh for the first time in
more than fifty years it was introduced
in the part in the eighties as i recall
it
edited run almost without molestation
ball that time
under my administration
we have practically
suppressed illegal again
we have plenty of
little para mutual general and i wonder
why that uh...
side of the question didn't appear more
playing in the newspapers around the
country
well ur certificate farmer and his
accomplices was seen as it did and they
work
bringing out whatever news they wanted
to bring out mister press and what
evidence it didn't want to come out he
was running for president he was not
uh... make in a moment by the
investigation is paying it
now so sense of terrorism to come back
to that said the accents serious
contribute about one third of the total
income of florida
as one of your uh... pleasures and
murder of his perhaps to invite before
the event on the tour for instance
howard yes sure had discovered you know
the finest
of the forty eight states
uh... with this old exceptional florida
which of course stand at the top of the
latest by any standard all measurements
i'd just come back from a
two of those two in the states inviting
everybody in those states who has not
already been departed become and those
who what where they've been there to
come back
and i should at this time like to invite
every person who is on her nose
less than we had a look at in on this
program and understand it's one of the
most popular programs in the western
world
i think i think i think for one of them
to come the flyer that we have about
five million annual business for part of
what we've got room for friday morning
around nine am governor just ask how
many days here is the sunshine
well audit schedule is three hundred and
sixty five days misses the schedule once
in awhile misdemeanors but
in saint petersburg is you know
publisher of the latest rate for
everybody in the year that this on the
eastern a little bit
some of the day v still in business
he's deliberate isn't going to call yes
not just now but it didn't go to shape
is that malanje watches
capable
where governor to come back to uh... the
national political scene which of your
is a particularly energetic
just uh... how do you believe this
delay action will go on november the
fourth nineteen fifty two dollars mister
if you if you flatter me
back to me if a lot
appears to be uh... opinion amanda you
appear to be estimate an opinion among
as i've said i've been in there
politics on
mostly on outer fringes of it for about
twenty five years
uh... more than half of my lifetime in
all i can do is make a guest in there
you go wild guesses
comical out yet
and say you can answer your question
that the republicans in nineteen fifty
two eight-b_
will be defeated
worse than they've been since nineteen
thirty six eight d
emily character displacement
evening florida will be any
democratic
yes sir i do and i'd like to give you a
mystery in a few of my reasons for
believing that
in florida we have
approximately one million one hundred
and eighteen thousand registered
democrat for the big beyond me
and we have about the economy
republicans in about five thousand
independence
i don't believe that the most
crack dealers and know you've man
couldn't believe that they would be
another sergeant among those
one million one hundred may eighteen
thousand democrats
to give the republicans of victory
we got a little taste of republicanism
in nineteen twenty eight we never have
recovered permanent part of mister i
mean
we got another military started in
nineteen fifty when one of our county is
from dallas county
went republican industries people are
still weeping over it almost
uh... we just can't testify makes it
seems to go with republican is we don't
like hard times we love prosperity down
and we've got it under the democrats are
not sure that there is a very much
appreciate seeing you tonight and thank
you for being with us
later this year
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting problems go clause mister
william bradford killing
and macedonia pain
our distinguished guests was the
honorable for a walk governor of the
state of florida
it's world series time again
the vast areas of the year for baseball
and this year again the world series is
launching time
c_s_o_ leon hotmail connecticut and
national baseball leagues use launching
lots of exclusively for driving all the
games including the world series
truly the most honored watch in the
world of sports is launching the world's
most on it walks
the only watch in history ever to end
their morals their grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and so many hours for
accuracy in fields of precise timing
that is why throughout the world no
other name on a watch
carries the prestige of laundry
the world's most pollard watchin sports
the watch our first choice less
discriminating people the world over
and yet the you know
that you might buy a m home
or probably give a launching watch for
as little as seventy one fifty
long-chain the world's most on iraq
premium product of the launching but no
one to come
since eighteen sixty six
maker of what
some the highest down
we invited to join us for all the
launching prosto
television journal of the important this
is all they are
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most all of our
distinguished companion to the world all
night long gene
this is ninety nine
reminding you that on c_n_n_ with
wal-mart
are sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
who proudly display of this error
agency although i'm jeanne what lala
enjoy that jackie gleason's you're on
the c_b_s_ television network
time for the continent promised
television journal of the important
issues of the aisle
also you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
launching the world's most ahmedabad
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
a daunting
good evening this is frank night
may i introduce our color because for
this edition of the launching cosco
mister william bradford healing
editor of the american mercury
and mister hennelly has left
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
as mister three of them are caught
former assistant united states attorney
general
domestic auto now that you were back in
the private life and done with being a
bureaucrat
perhaps you can tell us something about
the pressures that were brought on you
when you are assistant attorney general
what kind of pressures are they
well with the heads of the places well i
was sitting there for the mission
if you can understand that
but they came largely from the suburbs
of the congressman almost continues
today
from the
prominent men in public life that
normal here
they come in the form of telephone calls
and visits or what
women of communications of course what
will the telephone
but there were many many conferences
that were head with sandwiches
and congressman
in my office and so they have beyond
woohoo
is so busy i would accommodated you'll
go to his office
what would be a typical request
took on request
with tax cases for example involved
o_d_s_ when i was in the text of the
agent excuse bball by i remember one no
who's troubled me a great deal what will
swallow raven love dot
when was one of the american
parachuted leatherman
quote him some of the time that with the
vice president would be called me about
role for the view download
florida favor from you sir
well so he was he was uh...
he was concerned about the
the interests of this fellow
cannot deliver but he came to see me
about pastries was sick of some of the
six oaks what was wrong
and i thought of that
the doctors
government office building
that the ordeal of which i would not
result in the jet was definitely
there was no alternative but to go ahead
with his view cameras today are told
that that is very little
for the first period of course here this
man failure from north carolina at yes
of lost him
them for about four years you were and a
ed
tax division of the uh... department of
justice that's right here that day
say it started a the prosecutor attacks
case so as to settle it
yes or you know that that's what brought
you aren't always fresh that's right
um...
unfortunately you can't don't keep this
power to another who lives in your
absence
and you really have to say that all is
committed to add a appearing on the
president's afterall barricaded
yes i do remember will solely
etiquette
michigan
uh... taken every edit it
sticking petrified all is good friends
you're going to be a transparency is
also
i dot e book limited though would be
when the ah...
when you left me a orthotics what's your
theory is that the president
saying that you acting
gave you the clue such specs
it would take too long ago too much with
them popular arab yours of course no
your
whether they've made man uh... your your
wife at least de tocqueville matter
westwood maricopa glad she got away with
paypal i will continue to flee for their
within the last part though
and hands are better than bank code
eventective with
how much meat dot i believe it did
used to live as a meeku
mother whose
along with the solo one one for so long
and she argued that
to unless the ten-year as this room of a
to be renovated just alone so you know
that he was all right
i thought it was time to get into
toshiba
or specific days charts with whenever u
outside activities
i've been trying to find out
outside activities what
that is made in trailers for your
friends idon't know is one of those
things that uh... with the president
ought to know that their digital
equipment outside the found i've been
trying to find out
but the house at the front
domestic or you're out and i don't know
at the end of one of the committee
hearings the chairman of the
subcommittee had congressman king a year
ago
resurgence judy and recreation your
trust in the done irreparable damage to
the government now
what is your comment on that state and
he said he said i had
uh... don't feed you send to my blog
and i've seen you have to have it with
women
chairman sees working within a month
he he did give service to his government
and he did a disservice to the honorable
people matej division
any time i get stephenie
minutes actually as you saw it in the
four years your
iran test expectations you have any
cases that u_s_ makes japan's of prop
the sixteen thousand suitcases
probably forty five percent more
compromises settled
and of talks between five hundred income
tax fraud case
say at least cases easier i i'd like to
tell our viewers
uh... you get
calls from members of congress uh...
during this period barrel individual yes
uh...
and those members of congress is a
warning to the to uh... favorably
considered their constituents asap
yes so they have as a part of the system
is only a stable they will
of strong representation has been made
to the gentleman the war on the ball and
all of that relations with the
of the work and some of them was
convinced that uh... i was about to do
the justice by inviting someone
and of course i'll try to convince a
comes from that i had no located because
the fact was so strong that it just had
to be done but i'd like to take up one
specific case let's take the case of the
kansas city vote frauds
now you were in on that for awhile
that's why you hauled in by anybody or
anything steffi and by yourself
most of the changes to the
investigation
allows films from
of the many calls that we received we
have complaints from individuals out in
the congressional district
that uh... congressman expelled and the
comes from strong others this was a
nineteen forty six years of that was
when i was not going to expel was the
uh...
congressman that uh... the democratic
candidate
the president truman favorite
yes and it was it was argued that fraud
was used to elect him although his
democratic opponent eighty s so that it
was a case a friend a lot of that
to do is done about it in kansas city
early and then it came to your attention
is about right yes right
as a rad
just that way of information
uh... how does a man whose dentistry
could turn it down
and i had a c get positions such as you
occupied washington some senator bring
you there
most of them
most of the had anything to do with my
beloved weston
mister clark told me
would like to google office as you know
the state's attorney had louis trading
in the united states and
he would want to fill the vacancy
that he created by accepting
the the attorney joseph of the country
how he says that because of this for the
rest of which i have made
well he felt with the president
because they have decided to extend the
invitation to me in that was why i came
to washington
onion with some of the who who was a
vision and or something
and use of the baby
unloaded looming
of about the invitation from the schools
financially he moved to see him
personally nasd is getting says such a
position
that where you have the decision within
itself
others millions of dollars in tax cases
all of these calls that u_p_s_ white
house for members of congress
that's inherent in our system this is
the absolute it's enthusiasm
very very normal thing that woman who
has
who has to make the decision
its resources becky ogle i'd like to get
back to the to the specific cases we
took up because i think birthday
clarified the whole situation
if we went into something like that say
the kansas city most case now
you were called in on that and you
stadium for a while and then you work
tank in office
we are right and wrong what what
happened with the has it was
that uh...
this luminaries investigation this
preliminary investigation become quite a
famous memoranda
memorandum
the f_b_i_ has been completed his
fuhrman investigation is the increasing
alexander city hall yet so we can use it
if you're using the investigation to see
the stuff
yes we had uh... a fifty investigators
and there were a thousand people
interviewed him out of that number of
for eighteen hundred fifty-four
affidavits were taken
and that was a part of the preliminary
investigation report to me by the f_b_i_
because we had a lot of these things you
turned it over to the f_b_i_ round we'd
ask them to investigate as new too
too
to make a preliminary investigations
sold
to determine
we've got we've noted we had to eat
investigation it would cost a spanking
sum of money because we pay the cost
almost real evaluate our president call
you all fat investigational mode or
through his daughters it's recalled on
formal normal
and that most of
uh... i was uh...
uh... i receive i've never seen the
communique from the white house from any
source
and we all really believe that the facts
were not sufficient to warrant if other
investigation because we could not find
where that was in the air with the two
or more people conspired together to the
class will write little loves to cook
one of the important things to you
i believe this is in the last two or
three weeks you bunco undergone
extensive investigation washington but
it's just committee
hector waved germiston shelf uh...
at more or less rendered this judgment
which he said that your quote an honest
man who is indiscreet in his
associations an eggplant conformers to
the peculiar moral climate of washington
now etc
is that a fair description as
of your experience as a
well
i know that the chairman enmity keating
was right win these same to the american
people that are wise and on his way high
hamburgers agreed with them
at all and i know they're right
and look at the cute you are a prominent
washington europa kizlyar it
if is almost completely
i think you're right there's a loaf of
key is most peculiar mark climate u font
if you see the world everybody who gets
off at union station
only popped his call
comes in from the national airport
he goes to washington for something
and he disappointed if he does not
i see
well i'm sure that uh... there is a very
much appreciate these frank statement
should you tonight sir and thank you for
being with us
the opinions that you've read our
speakers expressed tonight our entire
lives at all
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching from scope laws mister
william bradford killing
and most of them rehab
our distinguished guests was mister
taylor marco
former assistant united states attorney
general
robots maker such as long gene recalls
that christopher columbus made his grade
voyages before the watch was invented
he's only timepiece
ann our class
like this fifteenth century one which
happens to be the property of the haven
planetarium
this of course have to be reversed
every half hour
style columbus day marks a milestone for
launching watches to because
this gold level
was presented to long gene that peace
and love us columbian exhibition which
all of the four hundredth anniversary of
columbus's discovery of america
now considering are consistently long
gene watches have maintained a
leadership over the years
long jane is the only watch in history
to win ten world's fair ground prizes
twenty eight gold medals and literally
thousands of awards for accuracy from
great government observatory
today's lol j mobsters
are are fine
distinguished for explosive styling and
other fellows traditional qualities of
accuracy and long life
poets launching watches off world dot
trolling
throughout the world no other name on a
lot
means so much as long gene
the world's most vulnerable
premium products
of along j macmall opt out
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest debt
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the launching costco
a television film of the important
dishes of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching in the
world's most part of our
and what
more distinguished companion to the
world on a launching
this is right not reminding you know
that on election day
you are the most important person in the
country
so exercise your privilege as an
american citizen
and hope for the candidate of yourself
a war war war war war on the artwork
block block block jews lol lol
on gene watches that one can wear a
program prizes forty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other countries
launching the world's most honored
watches made and guaranteed by the
launching what more what company
and i'm gonna flaunting monica
television general of the employers in
the intent of the hour
haha you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry much lol
what government
later on
laundry the world's most ahmed watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on and on june
believing that this frank night
mail and reduce our co-editors with its
addition all the launching products co
mr donald i rogers of the new york
herald tribune
and mister william bradford healing
editor of the american rectory
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable and brewster
united states senate uh... problem and
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
to procure audience carcinoid tumors
finger shana senior senator from maine
how long have you been in the senate
there
this is my
eleven p_m_
and what are your committee assignments
now sir
them on foreign relations and interstate
and foreign commerce
and i believe that our hands there
understands that you are one of the
three senators
who has just ah... rejected be
nomination non-productive jessup
uh... that's correct is mister yes there
was a subcommittee of five members and
uh... we've held hearings for three
weeks
and three of us more evidence is
confirmation senator smith
son of a new ad on the ground with the
laptop telecom problems
five voted against him on the ground it
could make himself understood
and i thought that was the first
qualification but diplomat
asunder
i believe that uh...
mister jackson
uh... background came into one of the
discussion
yes i did before
or not only from red china yes that was
the basis of the original attacked on
him in on the police's if he had
advocated
present status of the university of
pennsylvania had some very serious
charges and
substantiated them pretty well as some
of the evidence
removed from the world
that this might set a dangerous
precedent
in which
share of the past under instead of the
past beliefs of
every nominee would be scrutinized
brought forth to impugning today
my basis of criticism was his lack of
candor and
admitting the opinions he inhaled is
attempted cover-up
opinions which he obviously had held we
had
form and send a smith and uh...
mister special
general forty a m today apple core all
testified the understood from just that
that he a rather inclined to the
recognition of red china
he absolutely denies it it doesn't seem
all those
men could be wrong or else
he doesn't have the capacity
to make himself understood events
unfortunate in the bedroom and you'll
feel better only about him if he had
uh...
send one yet so i
and feel that way i think you would have
made a much better show and we had to
buy us down there
and we unanimously confirmed in the day
along with eight other delegates
and left a good just about the senate
acted today
purple my very great
gratification i was glad they took
missus roosevelt lauren austin out of
the class of
on the senator fused confirm so tat
suppose that you're quite popular with
the your colleague senator mccarthy now
as a result of this action
do you regard at your broker made
vindication of what
is common in owners mccarthyism
no i think the mccarthy charges
did not occupy as prominent a place in
this situation as
the friends of mister jessica desired
they started out to make a copy of the
issue rather than just that
but as a result of the entry of house
fastened
issue became just that
and his actions
this does to a measurable extent
vindicate
macarthur's original chudu year goal
that he felt that josip was the
architect of a far eastern policy
uh... senator smith
himself
agreed was one of the fundamental issues
that was the original mccarthy charged
now senator on that issue
uh... i believe that
you are well known supporter of senator
candidacy for the past and yes i have
long believed that he
was the logical nominee
you've known the senator for many years
as early as i voted farm for president
robert law review thirty years ago
do you think that senator taft
the number one can win the republican
nomination
i believe that he has a most excellent
chance i think he's a long ways tote up
today from what i've observed in the
country
and do you think that that the
republican nominee he would have a good
chance to defeat french crewmen i think
he'll make the kind of a campaign which
i believe the
republicans in the many americans warmer
a fight in campaign
that's the kind of a many years and
years
a tremendous uh... knowledge of
events that's one of his unique
qualifications
because the as an encyclopedic mine has
a dollars fingertips and what do you
think there will be the
principle of issue in the presidential
campaign i think that confusion
corruption
and communism
are all together like that would be the
major issues in the campaign
i think we have a great he love
ammunition on all those cause
confusion corruption and communism that
uh... you you expect that to be one of
the republican slogan i'd it's my slogan
of a rapid campaigns the f_e_c_
catholics
now i'm not going to the program that
you were wondering you know
many who
one hours the general eisenhower that
somewhere down the road
and i just a moment
activism and analyzing how are you
compared to the general eisenhower
mister captain came up with most of that
uh... no i wouldn't say that that was
the case i came back fully persuaded as
i stated that
general eisenhower was the indispensable
man
in europe
and i was very much gratified although
you might not agree
uh... to find that they are
times agreed to me the other day when
they ask cars bonded over in europe
add up to a column start of the same
effect
was that was very objective
politicians of sometimes
i thought that and hurt our tns would
like to do
spain because you've been active in
trying to obtain
more american aid for spain
i believe you also travel there
i don't know that several times and feel
very strongly about
the wisdom of a
cultivating bomb along
closer relations with them
now what is the basis of this error i
mean are you interested in
uh... cultivating them for military
reasons
is that every corner store owner who all
of our defense of fires that's one thing
on we have
which we have complete unification
the army because of the uh...
grounded as often
yac call because of the splendid
condition even operate all the year in a
very good airfields
and the navy because of the ports and
because it's the key to the
mediterranean
how we can ever expect to have a great
fleeing over there and the mediterranean
as we do now
without uh... x
job
sympathetic cooperation from spain is
incalculable
how then do we have all its opposition
opposition from the white house i think
it is emotional
and uh... ideological
the french and the british governments
now on the part of uh... been uh... very
critical of the bronco regina and their
many elements in this country who agree
if the british elections should go to
mister churchill there would be quite a
change in the british and it uh...
churchill
who was all through the war most earlier
that spanish picture
and i've discussed it with him this
summer and i know that he fully agrees
with those in this country who considers
spain
as the cornerstone
european defense quite parenthetical he
not only in spain uh...
do you think church you know has a
premature and that was the feeling when
i was there and apparently or at least
development centers indicator
the betting odds are very much in his
favor as they were in favor of mister
doing a couple years ago parents out
there and i can come back at the moment
in the military aspects of spain
uh... there are military authorities
believe that we can hold spain in the
event of a warm trail hearing these are
the best natural barrier in the world
probably via phone or you'll see a
running from the mediterranean to the
atlantic
and uh... almost impenetrable barrier
so that it would be very feasible in
spain has from one to two million men
who are good fighters whatever you think
about the spaniards are certainly
fighters as they demonstrated in their
own civil war malpractice that's right
and uh...
the opposition we were speaking of the
activities in our country through our
eight displaying and you said that it
was emotional
has been really busy if you are so many
important very well that was when i
return to our brothers bout of colin
about her own religious fanaticism
but uh...
that has been very greatly played up an
agitated and i think uh...
it has been done influence operating
very promptly in our state department
as manifest in variety of ways not a
finally announced a year ago january
they were going to nam allies relation
then this year
shown on the finally persuaded them
uh... that we must cultivate close uh...
military arrangements
and he was over there i was at the same
time
when his tragic death came why is it
that we haven't heard anything more
about it and send him a lot of the state
department is not doing exactly what
they did on china and exactly what
they've done in some other quarters they
are carrying on a slowdown on that
situation anup planning to sabotage the
program if they can and i think it is a
tragic below at the adequate
preparations about defense voice outside
of the money will grow created this
hundred we appropriated a year ago sixty
two million dollars it took him nearly a
year to distribute it
meanwhile they gave fifty million
dollars to yugoslavia
before they even had any authorization
that made the difference
those yugoslavia as a communist regime
while spain has a catholic ideology
and uh... that is apparently not
separable
to those in control in our state
department
and i think it's time the american
people understand it
and i had to stand your senator that you
believe that uh...
american dollars spent abroad can be
spent very effectively and spain
however thank you very much for being
with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry in promised ovr
mr donald i rogers and mister william
bradford hewitt
our distinguished guests one of the
honorable brewster united states senate
uh... from maine
i went to the museum of the city of new
york last time you got a picture of the
new york
of eighteen sixty six
the reason of course was within eighteen
sixty six in new york
the launching what norwalk company
opened its doors for that
they gave me this name has been named
riversdale insured from the hudson and
east rivers
but there were no bridges or somewhere
is no doubt
yet will lilian wu
already made their homes on manhattan on
this was the same when our government
traveler
by about five billion friend and i want
to
rust wrong laundry marker to find diller
throughout the left
what's path
is prelude it has been written
that's what the prelude to eighty five
years of leadership and they are
governed by and large menu
mandated
symbolized by cattle world fade grand
prizes
twenty eight gold medal awards
and highest honors for actors they from
the world's government observatory
for building
for greater accuracy and for the promise
of a long and useful life
these are the finest laundry marches
ever made
laundry in the world's most on ad watch
the premier product of the laundry mat
know what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of waters of the highest there
this is frank night again reminding you
that the logging promise go is brought
to you three times weekly
every monday wednesday and friday
so won't you join us
evening at the same time
the long jean pascoe
but other than journal of the important
it shows of the op
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored one
and what noah distinguished companion to
the world ahmed launching
sold and service from coast to go
by more than four thousand leading to
another
food proudly display the emblem
a doomsday
logon jeanerette
in time for the launching a promise kept
television journal of the implementation
of the opt closer you every monday
wednesday and friday a presentation of
the loved being let out what happened
later on
launching duluth most on it lost
and whatnot
distinguish companion for the world on
its own gene
friedman letters practi
may i introduce our brothers for this
edition of the mounting problems though
mister william bradford killing editor
of the american record
and mister kenneth kramer executive
editor of business week magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable robert asker united
state senator from oklahoma
the opinions expressed unnecessarily
those of the speaker
senator kerrey it's a pleasure to have
you this on your
return engagement on the promise cope
and it's uh... seems particularly
property heavy tonight because our
audience uh... have been looking at a
republican convention
and i dare say that a great many
americans have forgotten that there are
democrats who are running for president
so tonight sir we'd like to have some of
your impressions how the republican
convention
now why did you happen to here general
eisenhower's acceptance speech
no list hewitt i didn't
why not sick
well to tell you the truth uh... i've
felt he'd probably accept
and uh...
this car and i hadn't had our dinner so
uh... we went in a timely if he didn't
idea about the for long well i suppose
you didn't follow the the convention
very closely yes i did
what are some of your impressions of the
republican conventions
will the
the republicans uh...
have again demonstrated
that uh... a spin form
used making a record demand for months
running away from it
they have again refused to nominate a
man who had anything to do with the
making of the record that he's going to
have to run on
uh... they've selected uh...
uh... one cool
has had no part in uh... making the
record and so far as i know
no party and uh... in formulating the
program
for the future
do do you don't think that the
republicans have selected their their
strongest uh...
potential candidate
well our
that of course remains to be seen
the hamburg
they have at least disadvantage in the
man they've selected
he it doesn't
have the liability of any republican
record and uh...
unusual
however he used to have to
wrong on the record that they've made
then d
program that they have formulated now
nobody knows whether he even able
campaigner or not
uh... they've got uh... man who looked
very experienced campaigner t_v_ leno do
you feel that he will be able to conduct
as aggressively campaign has would have
senator task for instance
and not on the basis of the republican
program in the republican record no
i do not
uh... do you think senator taft would
have been able to have conducted a
better campaigner
well certainly senator test for them to
have the advantage in at least knowing
something about uh...
what the record in the program was uh...
and and uh...
and what his position was and what he
thought about it
when i was at the impression that uh...
to be in labs in our have been telling
the american people uh...
what he believes that for months now
distillers and out
well he's been indulging in lecturing
generalities where he said anything
on many questions he's uh... said i
don't know
i'll say this for him he's down to the
point now where he's gonna have to get
down to specifics
he's gonna find out that in this
congress that he said
apart of now that people are going to
expect in demand that he faced a cut
baggett
isn't the selection of eisenhower as a
candidate
going to change the complexion of the
issue says foreign policy for example
idea certainly not an isolationist he's
much closer to the democratic ticket
party-line on uh...
foreign policy as many i'm going to make
a campaign issue out of foreign policy
well uh...
if you have the opportunity to speak his
position on foreign policy and and it's
will move it's a force he's personally
concerned
he has supported the the foreign policy
in the name of this administration
fit you must remember this that uh...
he's not running a little he'd running
as a part of the party that have a slate
of candidates and uh...
they have candidates for the congress as
well as for the president samper
and uh...
should he win and should
they win
uh... and they should he favor the same
foreign policy in the future that he has
indicated he favors in the past
he'd find himself in the very calm
happy position of being the cap
of uh... of for his own party who
violently disagree with him and who
regardless of what
he thinks about it or says about it
would not let him have or carry out a
foreign policy
similar to that one which the democratic
administration
has carried out
but he has uh...
when been pretty clear and uh... saying
what he believes is the foreign policy
of this country what it should be and he
has been a participant in uh...
activating the policy we have today
volume lymphatic
he's been a protest from in carrying out
the policy of the majority party
right now if he becomes a part of the
majority party which is dedicated to
endeavor and foreign policy
bc eisenhower's been in the very
fortunate position just for being in
charge of whatever situation he was a
part
he will be commander in chief of the
issue
uh... chief of staff of that to the
president of something else
query his orders we carried out
now he thinks he can uh... give
that being removed within congress
wonders
and have been came out
you only get olsten cool inquired of
some evening and i have a heart to heart
talked with harry
but i don't get the facts of life about
how that will be examining sometimes has
to do with what congress does
it hasn't been true that in the
in the last two democratic
administrations we have
we've seen the chief executive uh...
believe the molder of the foreign policy
it seems to me that's going to be the
style weasley almaty seeing the cheese
eggs eighteen spent the majority of his
own party
and a minority of the opposition party
supporting him in that foreign policy
now if he has a great majority in his
own party
finding an ant
then he's going to find that uh... he's
under a handicap for with city he won't
be able to overcome anymore than he's
going to be able to overcome the
handicapped in this campaign
of of having to carry the republican
banner
march on the republican republican
record that run on their program
sunila brothel halo so i don't believe i
can carry
synthetic come back to the convention
uh...
perhaps points out that were there any
surprises there for you for instance
uh...
well we're surprised at general mikhail
anything in general macarthur speaks
all home a lot uh...
i heard in my partner's the him when he
made the first time
mandanna
i read about it when he made it the
second time
when our about your colleague as senator
dirksen is supposed to be the grey are
doing the republican party and i enjoyed
the angela dinner one senator's and had
the same
he was just enough of a realist and just
enough about
what was happening and what happened
said while he had me nation freeze
audience he proceeded to read the
obituary of the republican campaign for
nineteen hundred and fifty two
the senator that uh...
i'm sure that they're audiences
appreciated
your criticism the republican convention
but after all
in our facing the democratic plan and
you're one of the uh... three or four
leading candidates for the democratic
nomination thank you sir thing on here
and i i hope you look
get that message over to the convention
out in chicago
dominating then do you expect to have
any names do you expect to be placed
before the democratic convention i'm
sure there'll be a minimum of
pm candidate for president shouldn't be
american that and what is the eight
approximate delegate land up at the
moment sir who are the leading candidate
so i don't think that you don't want
mister russell and missed ke fall for
the two front runners i would say
that they'd have in the neighborhood of
three hundred peace
and where do you stand sure there
well i'm hoping that i'll be no worse
than fourth i think i'll have a minimum
of a hundred and fifty on the first
ballot and then uh...
uh... and more as we go along
uh... what what is the democratic uh...
campaign platform going to be isn't
going to be the
repeat that is are you going to follow
through on the truman program
well of course uh...
and nobody had would be presumptuous
enough to say what
the platform committee would bring to
the convention or what the convention
uh... wouldn't do it in the main of
course they'll approve it but they have
demonstrated in the past and sometimes
they re
uh... make such changes is they want on
the floor of the convention
i'd see this
demme's between the democratic party the
republican party is this
they spend four years making a uh... a
record and then four months running from
we spend four years making a record
and then four years running on that
record and on the proposals that we have
to improve it
for the following four years now serve
what our dances just seen the big bright
over the seating of southern delegations
and the republican convention
uh... what will be they say mollified in
the democratic convention but will your
big inter-party battle intra-party
battle be over well maybe a few contest
two delegations are ordinarily it's not
too many
and uh... then you have honest me aetna
hearing the comcast and
may end up equity and justice deciding
them
and then our convention will have that
confidence in their owned committees
and their own judges
that when the reports are brought in to
be a matter of routine to accept them
now so it is a final question will be
about the incident
yes some added how you think the
campaign will develop from this point on
and your prediction is that what you
think the outcome of the campaign me
well i think that day
the campaigns don't go like this mister
eisenhower has a great decision to make
general eisenhower pardon me
he's gonna have to decide whether to
make the meeting campaign
like to do and will keep did
embrace the democratic recruitment
program
poet aspen try to blaze a new train we
do not know that wherever he goes we'll
meet him
well thank you very much for being with
us
the editorial board for this edition of
the long dream crossbow
laws mister william bradford healing
and lester kena kramer
our distinguished guests was the
honorable robert after united states
senate uh... from oklahoma
the the results of the nineteen
fifty-one competitive trials at the
famous geneva observatory i've just been
published
first prize for the best watches in
category c
that responses
was one bottle on g
the centrist prize for the first
five watches in this class
was also one by along gene
and home twelve all the launching
watches and read
one-fifth of it
now that's a threatened another chapter
in the laundry in record of success
in observatory accuracy competition a
record which began in eighteen seventy
eight
and one more reason why through out
the world
no other name on a lot
means so much
as laundry
the only watch in history
to wind down world background rivals
and twenty eight gold medals
and so many honors for accuracy in
fields all precise timing
though every long he watches made
to the single long gene standard of
excellence
delayed by and all
or by and probably give the laundry
marks
for as little as seventy one fifty
forget what
albright prestige
is launching
the world's most are gone
premium product of the logging but not
what happened
since eighteen sixty six
maker waters
of the highest debt
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
fallen on being pumped up
a television journal of the important
because of the hour
broadcast on the top of long gene the
world's most only watch
and what not to forward
companion
for the world on a long journey
races frank night
reminding you of that launching and
whatnot
are sold and service
from growth
by more than
four thousand leading do it
probably just play with them
page and saying
caught on to name what nama
time for the launching promised us
television journal of the important
cases of the aisle
also you every monday wednesday and
friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
lunging the world's most on it watch
and what
distinguished companion to the world all
night long gene
good evening
this is david ross
may i introduce ella co-editors for this
edition of the laundry and promised
school
mister william bradford hwy
editor of the american mercury
and mister james h_ r_ cromwell's former
united states minister to canada
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable robert esker
united state senator from oklahoma
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers
senator kerrey says you're our
distinguished senator from oklahoma and
a candidate for the democratic
presidential nomination
supplies of heavy here tonight sir to
discuss some of your views with our
audience
now as a first question sir
where do you fit
in the democratic
how would you call yourself a new dealer
welfare dealer sir
in all turned into
mean just what
those
who used in intended amy
i have supported roosevelt and in the
may not have support room
i call myself the liberal
jeffersonian
i see
now what would you get a safe whether
you've got think of yourself as being a
truman fair dealer
all u_n_ dot
how u_n_ support of the
of what is known as truman's fair deal
that he's now insisting on has been
insisting on while he's been there
if i could be a number of things which
he is
foolish to have included it
update has been turned a fair deal that
i don't agree with
state medicines for instance socialized
medicine and uh... and uh...
as shown
the things which in michael and evolve
in the main
i am a liberal democrat
so that you
have quite a record
as the governor
of oklahoma
for having us believe
change the state deficit
tend to uh...
considerable
i believe that uh...
isn't it true that when you were in
office
the deficit was forty five million and
when you left at one point was the
situation in that interview that
mentioned in the oklahoma one ninety
eight four years later the explorer of
the day it had been paid and we had a
forty million dollar charity
well seminar
i ran a very interesting
little square than the paper the other
day be effected
war i think it was the year nineteen
forty four
that are uh...
federal expenditures were
and taxes
around forty four billion dollars
and uh... now in fifty two
with no war going on that said we're
going to spend on the stand between
eighty and ninety billion dollars
now as a man whose record is uh... so
excellent and trying to save money for
the taxpayer
how would you handle a situation like
that where you president
players at and i remember in nineteen
forty four the pact
income was under fifty billion dollars
but the total extended tour was around a
hundred billion dollars
those were the years in which we
increase the national babies you will
recall from
about forty billion door were two
hundred and
sixty billion dollars
nala uh... in the last five years
the
combined income of the government has
exceeded its expenses about a billion
dollars
this year we'll have a deficit of u_s_
however than that amount
next year greater
but we're paying as legal up
almost
and then in view of the fact that we
passed the peak of the defense spending
next year
i think we can and will be back
on a pair of legal basis
after the next fiscal year
to come back
to the democratic
some of the pair
as i understand that there have been
two movements in the party itself is an
improvement
toured uh... compromise and playing down
the differences within the party the
differences between the conservative in
the more liberal elements
and then lately
even on the part of the president
as well as other belligerent attitude on
the part of the new deal fair deal group
now a are you one of those uh... truman
belligerence that wants to drive on
toward uh...
more and more so-called social games
or do you believe that the time has come
for some compromise within the
democratic party
way all progress comes of that uh...
through compromise
there those who want to go faster than
others
i must say to you that i'm about in the
middle between the two extremes in the
democratic party has been delayed
uh... your
and that's just the president was
reported yesterday is insisting that
uh... the big issue in nineteen fifty
two should be
truman is something that he'd like to
see
uh... the reelection decided on the
issue truman is a man that he expected
to uh... stop the country in the same
man and he did in nineteen forty eight
well i'm sure that the president will
support checking
but he won't make issues he should have
been the kennedy
issue to be made by the democratic
convention in chicago in the new nominee
and i think it is your your you you're
ninety ranks as director make
truman is on the the issue in nineteen
fifty two
well i'm neither anxious to make it nor
to keep it
fahmed i recognize the reality is that
the issue will be
the record and program of the democratic
party on the one hand in contrast to the
lack of either on the part of the
republican party
how do you stay in some of that on the
so-called welfare state
you believe in that
and and and and what is you can
really known as the welfare state that
they should stay to do
all kinds of things for the citizen
in the second incessantly on the way
prime insurance social security
do suggests express the idea that you
did not approve socialized medicine i
believe never in uh... in in in a former
degraded when i am
floor of the things that you've talked
about
to my mind they built it
of themselves identify anything is a
welfare state that's just another turn
that federal government wants to the
people
and expected to serve them
and as it does show constructively
they will support it if it doesn't then
repudiated but the greatest service it
can render the people listed
improve the opportunity of an average
citizen to build his own security
but at the same time recognize that day
reforms and improvement in the way of
social progress and social security
which we have brought about part of the
people benefit and the people in the
cable
senator i'm sure that i always feel like
a few questions
on yourself
now i believe it is true that you were
one of those tremendously wealthy
elements of the southwest
you plead guilty to that so i haven't
told you all with a few years been a big
ritual man and then they go out and
proven wrong system where you are the
biggest and richest man in that there's
a running this time
for programs like that that's that's
i'm dave briefly a little illustrate
that when i started to run for governor
i thought the harmony for me
and tools we have more
but they found out i was going to be
learned that hurt me
and i'll tell you in the movie was found
out that moral man it almost beat me
when i do you see anything in congress
uh...
anything unusual
without a big rich oklahoma alone and
being such a
if irish supporter
uh... of of truman as a more of the new
deal dora social legislation i've said
this before and uh... in spite of the
fact is that they can only say dat you
should have seen me in my family under
hoover
we made every dollar we've got under
truman and road
and so far as i know most everybody else
did i venture to say maybe that you did
and i believe this that those who have
improved their conditions under a little
note in truman's
for a continuation of that program and
those who have suffered
might be justified in voting against it
there's one other question that i
believe you have uh...
it's true that you're a bad descend
sunday school teacher uh... rather pious
man isn't that
well i'm a bad business on the screen
creature i make no claim to being passed
says you have that background so you
have is a whole this corruption and
scandal
was and an indication of the radon in
washington
uh... what have you thought about that
sick i'm just as much against nafta is
uh... any other good red blooded
american citizens can be
and all of the you think you could clean
it up but i like to it
uh... are you
speaking generally sir do u as a citizen
and as an american
are you concerned about the fact that
the federal government may be gaining
too much power over the individual
citizen of this country
i'm always concerned about the level of
government gaining too much power over
the individual citizens
your suspicious of power all away
wherever it may be economic power or
governmental power
do you believe in these uh... very large
expenditures for are made
i have supported the foreign aid program
does
fodder
provided
believing that it was uh...
buying this
a greater amount of national security
then any other of the defense
expenditures we made
uh... just towards their own your own
campaign plan
uh... would you could you tell our
audience something about uh... what you
expect to do between now and the
convention value entered in any other
states
i'm not entered in any other state
primary
i'm visiting every state that i can
reach i'm speaking to the democratic
conventions and gatherings in those
states
and making myself is well known as i
came to the delegates and eight
alternates
and to the people generally how many
delegates do you expect to have uh...
committed to you
uh... by the time of the convention
layout i'll add this
that i would have more than i expected
and as as a final question sir
uh... it's been uh... alleged in stated
by people on both sides that perhaps is
some danger
of both parties nominating the same and
this time
now first uh... do you think that there
is any likely
root of both parties nominating the same
individual for president but i think if
there any possibility of it'd be a great
danger but i don't think there's any
possibility a
and he urinated event you wouldn't be in
favor of any such thing military
demanded won't be care that republican
banners afford i'm concerned when i have
to carry it all
as your though it is very much
appreciate your views tonight show and
thank you very much for your position
overview
the editorial board for the solution of
wrongdoing promise gulf waters
mister william bradford huey and mister
james h are cromwell our distinguished
guests for this evening was the
honorable robert iska united state
senator from oklahoma
do you have the problem of selecting the
gift of great prestige was someone
important to you
for father on father's day for instance
well that problem is most happening
solved with laundry the world's most are
not watch
because of the outstanding quality of
the watch itself
and because of what the name launching
stands for
to the whole world laundry nd stands as
the only watching history to win the
highest of all the wards thirty eight
times at world's fairs and international
expositions including ten grand prizes
and twenty eight gold medals
plunging the world's most honored watch
also stands for the water first choice
in sports deviations science and other
fields of precise timing
and long gene stands for the watch
to be classified for
at the four great government
observatories washington
geneva
if you're driving from and not have
health
the gift of great prestige for any
occasion
a father on father's day or for your
favorite graduate is launching
the world's most honored watch
and throughout the world no other name
on a watch means so much
yet you made by and own or by and
probably give along gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most honored watch
premier product of the launching with no
watch company
since eighteen sixty six maker of
watches of the highest character
this is david ross speaking for your
regular host frank night
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
for the long gene krupa school a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of laundry
the world's most honored walk
and britain all distinguished companion
for the world are not laundry
sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to
others
we'll probably display this emblem
agency it belonged gene quick norwalk